la partie va commencer tout le monde
dort s'il vous plaît dormez dormez
dormez dormez dans mais s'il vous plaît
dormez dormez dormez dernier
[Musique]
et
le village se réveille et
malheureusement nous perdons une icône
à j'ai la rage
à j'ai la rage opéra all star à roue à
eau et ont fait
donc t'as pas voté pour silva tevez n'a
pas voté sûrement j'ai pas entendu ce
qu'il a dit mais par contre moi j'aime
bien ce que frau il dit y'a un all-star
entre guillemets cas pas voulu se
manifester quand ils ont dit qu'is à
voter contre lui ça fait une erreur
c'est une erreur qui qui pour moi ne
devrait pas passer faut le comprendre
j'ai commencéà jeu dans les maisons de
quartier dans notre maison de quartier
ça a commencé très tôt à l'âge de 11 ans
et comment j'ai kiffé mais en fait c'est
un jeu ludique qui nécessite la
réflexion faut beaucoup réfléchir faute
stratégique faut anticiper dès fois
3-4-5 nuit d'avant surtout quand elles
ou tu doit calculer les villageois les
rôles et tout c'est très ludique et
c'est ça que j'aime bien
m
ce
commercial depuis deux ans et j'ai
travaillé dur je cherchais les clients
je démarche et du coup soit le vendredi
soir le samedi on se connaît tous pour
faire un loup garou
pour décompresser un petit peu on
rencontre de nouvelles personnes on se
fait de nouveaux amis et en plus on voit
des personnes qu'on a qu'on a perdu du
coup c'est que c'est cool grâce à edwin
retrouve tous quoi c'est cool
là on devrait être normalement ce soir
entre 30 et 40 personnes à jouer après
je pense qu'il ya également des
personnes qui vont venir comme
d'habitude regarder en fait
regardez le déroulement de la soirée
j'ai grandi si je finis à côté à
courcouronnes c'est à cinq minutes en
voiture mais j'ai tout lu j'ai fait
toutes mes classes ici tout mon cercle
d'amis est ici aller à l'école quand on
était petit forcément et puis après on
aimait beaucoup joué voilà je joue au
football et au basket ball on aimait
beaucoup joué beaucoup rigolé on
débattait aussi quand même un petit peu
je pense que ça se retrouve aussi du
coup dans le dans les loups garous
co-organise c'est un moyen gratuit pour
nous de nous retrouver dehors ensemble
il fait bon on se retrouve en forme on
débat on joue on rigole et puis voilà
faut savoir que paris on est à 40
minutes de paris ici nous ici on est à
cinq minutes voilà on on vient à 5
minutes avec notre chaise comme tu peux
le voir et on rigole
vos gosses
du coup du coup du coup bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir à tous est-ce que déjà pour
commencer ce que tout le monde a déjà
joué au loup garou au moins une fois ce
monsieur tabelles chef avec sa belle
chef haute écoute
bonsoir ashley
hockey bonsoir mégane je connais jean
depuis 2016 on s'est rencontré en bts et
en fait on a commencé les loups en bts à
la place de suivre et nos coûts ont joué
aux loups garous après la troisième
année edwin a commencé à faire ça à
bondoufle au début je venais pas et
maintenant ça fait trois ans que je
viens tous les étés c'est un rituel tous
les étés celui-là et bah franchement
c'est trop bien parce que au début on a
commencé on était juste en cours et là
où fin là je le vois on y défend les 150
la plus grosse partie qu'on est ferme et
60 c'était incroyable et du coup d'oeil
par six voix ça prend des grosses
grosses proportions plusieurs fois tu
t'es mal défendu donc les attend au
tournant chers amis mais ça veut
strictement rien dire je suis désolé
pour moi ce n'était pas un boîtier pour
voter pour lui
merci mégane concrètement je suis un pur
villageois
j'aime pas votre pote couper la
france puisque je vois quand j'arrive
c'est s'aider sourire c'est une bonne
ambiance ya beaucoup de bonne humeur qui
se dégage de de l'événement et c'est
totalement aux antipodes de ce que
peuvent
nous véhicules et des fois certains
médias ou de tout ce qu'on peut voir à
la télé quoi en vrai c'est cette partie
là des quartiers qu'on ne voit pas parce
que en vrai des quartiers c'est vrai il
y en a qui font ils font ce qu'ils font
mais derrière est aussi ce qu elle aussi
cette partie là on joue à des jeux on se
détend on est aussi jeune en vrai mais
c'est juste qu'en fait on cherche des
choses qui vous permettre qu'on ne se
prennent pas la tête on va s'investir
dans le jeu